I know my boy here but he ain't gone
some days are harder than others some
days were able to to smile more than
other days but there are days when we
wake up and and and it's just hard you
know you wake up crying thinking about
it
[Applause]
I guess it doesn't get easier to sing
that song I'm sure because it's such an
emotional moment for you there's a
reason I do it towards the end of my
show like I've run a marathon it just
takes so much energy for me to refrain
or hold my emotions back and in order to
sing it that by the time I'm done with
it I just feel worn out I feel beat up I
also do it because I do know that even
though it might hurt me to do it I do
appreciate the positive impact that that
song is having on people's lives thank
you for the song it is absolutely
beautiful and so many people think that
song is beautiful including some guy
named Blake Shelton you're on Kelly
Clarkson's show and she surprised you
with Blake Shelton it's a horrible
tragedy I can't even imagine but man you
know it's just such a great great song
what was that conversation after the
show when he and I are hanging out we
talk about the music a lot believe it or
not we're talking about our farms we
talk about our families with he and Gwen
and the kids there was a lot of
questions about that because it's really
funny to see Blake in that role oh yeah
he's a great dad he's done yeah he and
beautiful people and we just love him to
death will there be a collaboration
between you two never I don't like his
singing that will I don't know in our 15
or 18 20 year friendship for the first
time we just recently talked about maybe
doing something our friendships about
our families and our lives outside of
them you know I find it fascinating that
album title God family country which was
a song from your second album I love it
why use that song title for this album
well the material in this album that
title really encompasses the three
things that are most important to me and
I felt like every song on this record
old and new all encompass one of those
three subject matters